[Music]
good morning everybody seven o'clock
here in the united kingdom you are very
welcome to spend your breakfast with us
here at sky news wherever you're
watching us right around the world this
morning covered infections on the rise
in england and accusations the vaccine
booster program has slowed too much are
we heading for a return of restrictions
calls this morning from nhs bosses for
the government to trigger its plan b
now to avoid a winter crisis plenty to
ask the business secretary quasi quatern
on the show shortly plus the chief exec
of the nhs confederation who's making
those calls and
what do the scientists think we'll speak
to one who attends the government's sage
meetings in just a few moments time also
this morning for you we'll chat to the
couple who got so sick of pricey london
that they up sticks
and moved into their van
yay
don't we all want to do that sometimes
quarter to ten on the show and
[Music]
swinging singapore will speak to the
co-founder of a sidecar business about
tourism returning after more than a year
of international covered restrictions
later on this hour it's wednesday the
20th of october hump day
winter warning nhs leaders call on the
government to reintroduce their plan b
with some covid measures such as
mandatory mask wearing as infections
rise
misogyny is a hate crime we meet the
police forces recording gender-based
abuse against women despite some mixed
messaging from the government there's no
getting around the fact that it is a
gendered problem it is men harassing
women
families feeling the squeeze will bring
you the latest inflation figures live
this hour and analyze what it means for
your household bills
i'm live in west london as police search
for a driver involved in a suspected hit
and run that killed a 23 year old woman
near the television center
as lava continues to spew from the mouth
of comber vieja scientists warned the
canary islands president that there's no
evidence the eruption is coming to an
end these are live pictures from la
palma again this morning she's not
giving up yeah is she
and eruption in japan with residents and
hikers want to avoid the volcano there
[Music]
good morning life has uh seemed like
it's been gradually getting more back to
normal since the last lockdown with more
people back at work and also going out
with family and friends but
could we be heading for a return to some
restrictions this winter there are calls
this morning from nhs leaders for the
government to trigger its plan b now and
reintroduce some measures such as mask
wearing in some places to avoid
stumbling into a winter crisis it comes
amid rising infections and criticism the
booster vaccine rollout is happening
just too slowly
uh the business secretary with us in
just a moment first let's remind you of
what plan b is what it looks like it's
something like this under the plan the
public could be told clearly and
urgently about the need to exercise
caution to help control the virus face
coverings would once again become a
legal requirement in some settings
and the work from home mandate could be
reintroduced
and the government would also have the
option of making covid vaccine
certificates mandatory in certain
scenarios well let's talk about it in
more detail should we join now by the
business secretary quasi quatting hello
to you good morning good morning don't
usually start with good news but
congratulations you're in order i
believe thank you very much new baby in
the house it's very kind of how's it
going very well very
um and i'm very very pleased i bet you
are your wife is very happy as well and
she's okay
both well
very well thank you excellent i'm glad
to hear it thank you talk to me about
coverage what on earth is uh going on
more than 40 000 cases a day why is
there such a slow uptake of the vaccine
boosted you i think that's something
that we really need to address uh kay
and as you know it's open to everybody
over the age of 50 and also vulnerable
people and i would urge people who can
uh to take the booster jab because the
vaccination rollout has been the most
successful
thing we've done
and it's allowed the economy to open up
and as we opened up as we hit the uh
fourth phase on in july
it was it was clear that you know we had
to live with uh the virus and it was
likely as we opened up that there would
be more more cases now the critical
thing as my colleague the health
secretary has said is about
hospitalization and also
deaths and and thank god those figures
are much much lower than they were
certainly at the beginning of the year
although still going out 223 deaths
yesterday it's a situation that we're
concerned about
but you'll remember the beginning of the
year we had uh
hundreds if not thousands a day
but mercifully that hasn't happened
and as the secretary the health
secretary said it's something we're
going to have to live with and i think
we are managing the situation he went
further than that didn't he he said um
he said it was going to be a
particularly tough winter how worried
about you uh how worried are you i
should say about the
nhs being overwhelmed i think which is
always difficult as you know because
there are lots of things
uh going around lots of viruses and it's
a particularly vulnerable time for lots
of elderly people and people
in our country and also
for the health service i think with
coronavirus it does add an extra
complication
but we're confident uh that with the
vaccine rollouts with the extra booster
uh jab uh take up uh the situation is is
can be can be managed well okay let me
let me take you back to um older people
not wanting this vaccine booster now
you may remember i worked in a in a
vaccine hub
at the start of the year and one of the
concerns was a lot of older people came
in and if it was uh a pfizer booster if
it was a pfizer inoculation they didn't
want it they didn't want pfizer they
wanted astrazeneca if you've had
astrazeneca you're now mixing it with
pfizer
how are you going to convince them that
that is the right way forward and if not
would you consider bringing back azad
for older people i think we just have to
push the message and certainly at the
beginning of the whole vaccination
process
there were groups of people that were
quite reluctant uh to take up uh the
vaccination
some older people were particularly
people from ethnic minorities but we
actually did a good job in encouraging
people who were reluctant uh to take up
the vaccination and that's what i think
we will be doing
certainly uh to drive up
how are you gonna make that happen
because it's not working at the moment
well i think i think it can work i think
people uh need to get together
what are we talking about we need to we
need to get the communication out there
and that's what we're we're doing and
that's what plan b
uh i'm sure will it will involve
and we we need to get people more
awareness
more uh
people more comfortable
uh with the difference between
that
i think for now we want to stick to the
pfizer and get the booster jab
campaign up and running and that's what
we're focusing on what's going on
well it's just communication making sure
that people understand
that the vaccination rollout is key
to protecting themselves and their
families and that's something that we
can keep people like me on shows like
this
can can keep pushing that message but
you have said that's what plan b would
involve so obviously and other things
and i mean you mentioned them you
mentioned the other issues what about
these walk-in centers because um the
walk-in centres are virtually empty is
what we're being told anecdotally
because people are being told they
shouldn't go to have a job until they're
called up by the nhs that's mixed
messaging no i i let me be very clear
about this i think that people who are
eligible for a booster particularly
people over the age of 50 other
vulnerable groups should be uh taking up
the booster jab because that's and
that's clearly the best way
that's clearly the best way to protect
uh themselves and also their families
and people they care what about and the
wider community sure of course that's
why we all have vaccinations isn't it um
12 to 15 year olds um
90 of them are unvaccinated why is that
not working 200 000 children off school
last week with covert i think i think it
is working but we just need a faster
rollout i mean it's it's easy to say
that things aren't working when they've
just started or we need to we need to
push them on for weeks we need to push
them more uh uh you know dynamically but
it but it is working you acknowledge
that it's not been pushed dynamically
enough at this stage well i'm saying
that we could always do better we can
always improve okay you know that uh we
nothing is ever going to be you know
perfect but we can be more um dynamic in
pushing it and that's what i would urge
people to do because 10 uptick's not
enough is that no um we need to we need
to to increase that okay uh plan b we've
been talking about uh plan b um
let me just ask you about sorry i forgot
about lateral flows are they going to
continue to be free um i think so um i
hope so but uh let's let's see what
happens because they weren't going to be
were they you were going to start
charging for them you weren't going to
give them away if people rang the nhs or
or went on to the app and ordered them
it was no longer going to be free but i
was reading the paper this morning that
that's a bit of a u-turn overnight is
that your understanding well i i i i'm
assuming that it'll continue to be free
but i don't know what the precise detail
is on that okay
plan b uh now hearing about plan b plus
do you know what that might be looking
at suggestions that there could be
restrictions on holidays again no i
don't think so look i think the the
conversation about restrictions on
travel restrictions on you know more
lockdowns is completely unhelpful i
think we've
had a huge job of work getting the
vaccine roll out to the point that we
could reopen the economy that was the
main thing we were focused on this year
that has worked and what we want to do
is manage uh the the situation as it is
we don't want to go back into lockdown
or into further restrictions did say
that this time last year though well
last year we we didn't have a vaccine
this time last year we didn't have a
vaccine
uh the vaccine has changed the com our
total approach to this and has given us
a measure of security which everyone is
enjoying and that's why we've managed to
open up these as long as people take up
the boosters yeah no i would say that
repeatedly i mean people should that is
very important okay um stephen reicher
who as you know is a member of sage uh
is advocating plan c and saying that we
can't rule out another lockdown no i i
would rule that out
um clearly
you know throughout this process
there'd been people saying
the lockdown was unnecessary and have
been other people saying we should
continue the lockdown
we've really plotted a path between
those two extremes i think it's worked
and that's why k one of the reasons
we've got the fastest growing economy in
the g7 it's 7.5 this year that's the
prediction which is faster than any
other comparable country certainly in
the g7 and there's a reason for that and
that's because we've managed to
successfully roll out the vaccine and
reopen the economy and that's something
that i think we're i'm very grateful for
okay let's just hammer home the point
before we go on to uh energy people
watching um this morning getting the
kids ready or half term or whatever it
might be you'll be finding yourself in
that position before you know it trust
me
you need to take up your booster the
kids need to be vaccinated in order for
us not to go back to where we were this
time last year
i think that's absolutely of a fair
um a fair message i think we should just
keep rolling out
uh the vaccination i mean that's what's
given us the security and the safety
that we've we enjoy at the moment and
you think we're going to have to have
those boosters every year
i don't know look i mean you know
we we have flu that comes back uh
regularly
um it may well be that kovid is is in
that in that category all i'm focused on
is this year and making sure that enough
people
get the boosters enough people are
double vaccinated because still not
everybody is double vaccinated um so
that we can give protection in the here
and now what happens next year and the
year after
uh is something that um you know we will
have to just wait and see exactly okay
talk to me about um the energy plan that
so
we heard about yesterday artemara has
been reading it she missed succession
last night so that she could read the
document and brief me up on it
it's certainly genuinely world leading
but a lot of people with old drafty
houses and diesel cars
are going to be saying how much is this
going to cost me i think that's a fair
question but if if you actually look at
what the strategy says
and what it's trying to do
is that it's trying to actually attract
huge amounts of private investment
into the uk
and what happens with private investment
is that the unit cost of the energy
actually is driven down it's lower it's
it's cheaper
and this is what happened with offshore
wind i mean if you look at back
even in 2012 40 of our electricity came
from burning coal today that's about one
between one and two percent
and the big difference has been uh
renewables
and if we look back over the last nine
years the cost of those renewables has
gone down hugely something like
two-thirds so more investment actually
in diverse energy sources
is actually going to reduce costs uh in
the medium and long term and i think
that's good our homes there's not these
heat pumps are not going to work are
they well the heat pumps uh we've got
boiler upgrade grants we've got huge
incentives for people
to make
that transition
and also we're we're making sure that
new build houses
have a higher standard of energy
efficiency
than older houses there's still issues
with retrofit we've had uh various
schemes and we're looking at schemes uh
now to encourage people and also to
incentivize um making sure that our
homes are more energy efficient
shouldn't the government be saying from
today any new house that is any new home
that is built in the uk should have a
heat pump we're not having gas boilers
in new homes anymore so there are a
range of sources of of energy uh supply
um heat pumps are
a great source we want to increase that
there are things called heat networks if
you live in apartments and i've seen
them in in london particularly
and they're going to be
more widely adopted so yes heat pumps
are absolutely central but there are
other forms of
carbonation there's gas boilers should
not be being put into houses that are
being built from today yeah i mean we've
said that the gas spoiler will be will
be phased out um
why do that why not just say because as
you say it's it's it's very costly i
mean what we don't want to do i mean
it's a fine line you have to tread
between making the transition
and essentially forcing people
and posing costs on people uh to make
the transition and what we want to do is
to keep people
uh with us on the transition on the
journey yeah um just to take you back to
insulating homes so you know my hou my
home is old and drafty and uh because of
where i live i can't do anything with
the windows etc so there it is very
challenging for some people i'm sure i'm
not the only person there'll be lots of
people watching this morning in a
similar position it is challenging i
mean we've been we've gone through these
transitions before people forget this
but you know when we went from town gas
to natural gas that was a huge
uh nationwide drive over many years and
the town gas was was filthy stuff and we
managed to transition to natural gas and
this is uh another transition we're
saying that um we can actually have a
more a cleaner more sustainable
environment and most people want to see
that
i'm always struck by the numbers of
people young people in particular that
are very infused uh by this and they
really want us to get going and as usual
people are saying some people are saying
it's it's too expensive and we're moving
too quickly a lot of other people are
saying we're not moving fast enough and
that's an important debate to have in a
democracy i'm talking about how much um
it's going to cost to power industry
given the increase in
energy prices um obviously you sort of
seem to get
get across purposes with um the treasury
over that a couple of weeks ago
and they were saying that you were
basically making things up i don't know
where that came from must have made you
very cross i'd have been very cross if
people were telling me i was telling
porcus um you know i speak to the
chancellor we speak together you would
expect people responsible people
watching this program would expect
government departments to be talking to
each other and that's exactly what we do
i don't know where that remark
particular market well i do because it
was somebody from the treasury who spoke
to our deputy um
deputy political educator
and they said he's just making it up i
don't know anything about that um trust
me that's trust me i'm not lying to you
that's what that may be what happened
but then you remember
you know we said that we we speak to
each other all the time
uh the prime minister number 10 said uh
we speak to as you would expect you
expect the secretary of state for the
business to be speaking to the
chancellor and the team's relevant teams
to be talking and another i do which is
why i can't understand that they would
say something like that it's just
divisive well maybe you should ask them
yeah and but because you're here i'm
asking you
no i just want to say that we have a
very good relations i'm going to speak
to the chancellor yesterday um i saw him
a cabinet and uh he congratulated me on
the birth of my child so well i'm sure
he's relations are very cordial i'm sure
it certainly is uh with him so you're
just writing about any nonsense that we
said well i don't know where these
comments come from uh they're not
helpful they were much more diplomatic
than they were they're not true either
we talk all the time okay it's good to
see you and congratulations thank you
for the birth of your little girl what's
her name ida ida lovelyness thank you
very much for joining us thank you
uh now coming up we are going to be
talking about booster jabs um and uh you
heard what the business secretary had to
say there we really need to get those as
quickly as we can so bear that in mind
more on that and also uh we'll be
talking uh to the labour party uh in
just a few moments to uh time as well if
you want to get involved in any of the
interview that we have covered for you
today you can check it out of course
online
um and uh
what else would you like me to do guys
uh but over four million of people my
autocue's not helping me out very much
thank you very much indeed for joining
us thanks a lot um so
okay still to come on the program we got
there eventually didn't we still to come
on the programme for the nhs
confederation calls on the government to
implement a plan b for containing
coronavirus cases this winter we'll
speak to the chief exec at 7 35
as the world continues to open up we'll
head over to singapore to see how the
tourism industry there is getting its
wheels in motion once again
and at twenty five state we'll speak to
labour's shadow chief secretary to the
treasury bridget phillipson as they call
on the government to do more to protect
the living standards of millions of
people in the country
breaking news this morning for your
latest inflation figures are out helen
allen is here hi what do they say good
morning kate so inflation uh the 12
months to september the bridge has gone
up by 3.1 percent that's actually
fractionally lower than what inflation
was last month uh last month the 12
months to august inflation jumped up by
the a huge amount the biggest on record
to 3.2 percent so uh
so it looks on the surface like that 3.1
fractionally lower perhaps a little bit
of good news perhaps a bit of cooling in
the economy but that actually really
doesn't tell the full story at all
because last month for 12 months to
august there were a few particular
reasons why inflation was very very high
indeed not least that eat out to help
out scheme that we all had we all
enjoyed those big discounts a year ago
in august so actually a lot of
economists will be saying that little
ever so slight drop in the rise of
inflation this month actually nothing
really uh when you look at kind of the
fact that the economy is still very very
hot prices still rising very very high
and the real concern is that a lot of
those forces that are pushing inflation
up absolutely likely to continue into
the awesome energy price we've heard so
much about that haven't we okay the
supply chain crisis the labor crisis all
of these things big costs on business
and those ultimately likely to get
passed to the consumer the september
figures they really matter because they
set business rates uh going forward the
amount that businesses are going to pay
the september inflation figures also set
the state pension as well so these
figures are very important and of course
kay as this inflation this heating of
the economy continues a lot of eyes as
well on the government of the bank of
england will he put those interest rates
up there was a bit of a hint from him
over the last couple of days the action
might come the next meeting of the
monetary policy committee that committee
that sets interest rates that's on the
fourth of november uh a real question
over whether he will choose to raise
interest rates up from that historic low
that they're currently at good to talk
to you thanks very much indeed thank you
still to come on the program for you
should misogyny be classed as a hate
crime it's a question that's been asked
of the government many times in recent
weeks following the sentencing of the
killer of sarah everard prime minister
isn't keen saying he believes it will
just stretch the police further but some
forces are already recording sex and
gender-based abuse against women as a
crime as becky koshal reports
staying in during the pandemic was hard
for claire as it was for many
she missed nights out but not the way
men often behave towards her and other
women when a stranger harassed her
outside a club she decided to go to the
police
they phoned me back and said actually
the profile of the guy fits a prolific
offender who's been doing this for years
and is out of prison on probation for
related offences of sexual harassment of
women and they basically said this is
probably going to send him back to
prison
the reason claire reported her
experience was because she lives in
nottingham she knew the police there
record certain crimes against women as
acts of misogyny i think it's a really
powerful thing to have police forces
actively saying we want you to report
these things even though some of them
seem a bit small and seem a little bit
trivial there's no getting around the
fact that it is a gendered problem it is
men harassing women
nottinghamshire police became the first
force in the country to record misogyny
in 2016. the underlying crimes for
instance sexual assault are already
covered by existing law but if a woman
is targeted because of her sex or gender
it's recorded as a hate crime the same
as if someone was targeted because of
their race or religion
research found this policy has
encouraged women to report harassment
but just under two years after the
programme started of the 73 reports
recorded as misogyny hate crime only one
led to a conviction
a quarter of police forces in england
and wales now track hostility and
violence towards women essex has just
become one of them
what we want to understand is first of
all victims coming forward where is it
happening who is it happening to and
more importantly for us the people that
are committing these crimes so that's
why sex and gender is now recorded by
essex police
want what essex and nottingham are doing
to be rolled out nationally but say the
police are also part of the problem
there's a whole plethora of
interventions that are needed to
eradicate misogyny within the police
just like in wider society at the moment
we know as refuge only one in five of
the women that we support will report to
the police they have absolutely no
confidence in them
the prime minister doesn't support
making misogyny a hate crime he worries
it will be an extra burden on police
but it could mean harsher sentences for
crimes like stalking and domestic abuse
whether long term it will increase
reporting and conviction rates will
determine whether this policy can make
women safer becky cottrell sky news
we are going to talk more about that
later in the programme with the former
nottinghamshire police chief and that's
cons uh chief constable for giving me
sue fish and that's at 20 past nine
other news police are appealing for
drivers with dash cam footage to come
forward after a young woman died in a
suspected hit and run in west london uh
near the television center there
aisha is standing by for us hi i should
tell us more
well the incident happened here onward
lane yesterday morning it's an
incredibly busy road right near the a40
westway junction
in very close to the television center
as well police were called out after
receiving reports that there was a
person in the carriageway they arrived
alongside paramedics the first crew of
paramedics arriving within less than
five minutes but unfortunately it was
confirmed at the scene that the woman
who they believed to be 23 years old had
lost her life
now they believe that this was a hit and
run police said that she sustained
injuries that you'd expect to see after
a road traffic collision and that no
driver stopped at the scene so they're
very much treating it as a hit and run
appealing for any information any
witnesses and anyone with dash cam
footage to get in touch
okay thank you
thanks very
much if you've got dash cam footage
contact uh the police young girl um
killed um possibly by a hit-and-run
driver they want to know more
information about that it was near
television center yesterday morning
looking at some of the other stories
making headlines for you this morning
the foreign secretary liz truss is
heading to the gulf today in a bid to
boost economic and security times with
saudi arabia ms trust will meet her
saudi counterpart prince ryzel bin
fahren and the emir of qatar
as britain moves closer towards starting
negotiations with the gulf cooperation
council which includes both saudi and
qatar
north korea has confirmed that it
successfully tested a new submarine
launch ballistic missile the report from
state media comes after authorities in
south korea and japan detected an
apparent weapons test yesterday north
korea has released these pictures
believed to be the launch not known
whether leader kim jong-un attended
a warning some domestic abusers are
using their victims immigration status
to control them a report by the domestic
abuse commissioner found that some
migrants are being forced to stay with
perpetrators because they can't access
the money that they need to escape
and more on that story for you when
nicole jacobs will be joining us on the
program that's coming up just a little
bit later on as well
now have you thought about the songs
that you want played at your funeral i
know cheery isn't it not something we
always like to talk about but music
often makes up a big part of
personalizing our send-off new research
has found this year's most popular songs
that the british public plays at their
funerals are some of these but can you
guess what's in the top three let's
start with number three should you is
from 1979
and it is always look on the bright side
of life
yup number three is always look on the
bright side of life from monty python's
life of brian
uh played uh where uh brian uh
is um yeah
if you haven't seen it of course you've
seen the movie he's crucified isn't he
and that's what happens how about number
two what is that then
classic number two frank sinatra's i did
it my way
but what do you think then because you'd
have thought that would be number one
wouldn't you what is going to be
at number one bit of a clue football
[Music]
actually all emotional uh jerry and the
pacemakers of course uh their version of
you'll never walk alone number one many
of you will know this song as the anthem
before liverpool fc and it's been
thought to have been played at more than
9 000 funerals in the last year alone
you'll never walk alone
a quick look at what would you have
played at your funeral why don't you
send me a tweet and let me know at
cabernet what do you want to hear at
your funeral is it you'll never walk
alone is it always look on the bright
side of life
let me know your thoughts at cave early
quick look at the weather next few days
will be colder with bands of rain moving
through to leave blustery showers
la palma's volcano's second river of
lava is expected to hit the ocean later
on within hours we're told causing more
explosions and noxious gas to be
released into the atmosphere the volcano
has been erupting for almost four weeks
destroying everything in its path and
causing mass evacuations among residents
live shot for you uh from the volcano
here we go
my goodness me let's have a quick listen
well la palma isn't the only place
currently experiencing volcanic activity
talking about la palma later on in the
program in more detail volcano in
southern japan though as well that's
erupted sending a massive column of grey
smoke billowing into the sky there as
well concerned for the animals there i'm
sure authorities have raised the warning
level for mount aiso to three on a scale
of one to five warning hikers and
residents to avoid the mountain i think
if you saw that spewing out of the top
you would probably want to avoid it
anyway wouldn't you but that's the
warning is on
level three um that's a quick look at
our climate change indicator as well
should we
top line as you know by now is how much
fuel we're using as a percentage uh 23
fossil fuels today that was much higher
last week we're back to using quite a
lot of renewables now
the one below 1.23 degrees how much
warmer we are now than we were in 1880
when records began below that how long
it might take according to some
scientists to get to a level of 1.5
degrees celsius the point of no return
say some 11 years and counting says our
calculator this morning and the one at
the bottom is the millions of tons of
co2 emissions
reminder that you can get all the latest
on the sky news daily climate show which
airs every weekday evening at 6 30 live
on sky news we're the only ones that do
it
now a deadly stowaway snake has found
its way to the uk after being discovered
in a shipping container from india
it's a sore scaled viper and it's a
species of snake i'm not looking thought
to have killed more people than all
other species combined thankfully though
it's been contained in a box and is
living in a sealed room at south essex
wildlife hospital it's hoped a suitable
facility will be able to give the snake
a proper home soon he's not coming to me
is all i'm saying still to come
as the nhs confederation warns that the
uk needs to implement a plan b to
prevent the uk stumbling into a winter
crisis we'll speak to the group's chief
executive matthew taylor
[Music]
calls this morning from nhs leaders for
the government to trigger its plan b now
and reintroduce some measures such as
mask wearing in some places to avoid
stumbling into a winter crisis it comes
amid rising infections and criticism the
boost of vaccine rollout is happening
too slowly i asked the business
secretary earlier if we could ever see
another lockdown the
conversation about restrictions on
travel restrictions on you know more
lockdowns is completely unhelpful i
think we've
had a huge job of work getting the
vaccine rollout to the point that we
could reopen the economy that was the
main thing we were focused on this year
that has worked and what we want to do
is manage uh the the situation as it is
we don't want to go back into lockdown
or into further restrictions did say
that this time last year though
well last year we we didn't have a
vaccine this time last year
we didn't have a vaccine uh the vaccine
has changed the com our total approach
to this um stephen riker who as you know
is a member of sage uh is advocating
plan c and saying that we can't rule out
another lockdown no i i would rule that
out
so there tomorrow no more lockdowns yes
rather chilling reminder of last winter
when the government thought that the nhs
could cope over christmas and of course
we ended up with a very severe lockdown
in january the cabinet minister says
we're not having another lockdown talk
of lockdowns and travel restrictions is
unhelpful he says and while it would be
a tough winter and that's what the
health secretary said yesterday the
prime minister is saying that
hospitalizations are broadly flat the
problem is of course that we now have
the highest rate of new cases in europe
and
they are in schools they are across the
country and the government's very
concerned about the slow rollout of the
booster program i can tell you that
we're going to get a big
information campaign starting on friday
encouraging everyone who is eligible for
a booster which is everyone over 50 and
those who are vulnerable to go and get
one because why would you tell me that
when i was asking him yeah because
wailing immunity is the the message of
that campaign is that waning immunity is
real we had our we had our successful
vaccine roll out early in the year that
immunity does wane over time and people
do need to go and have that booster if
they are eligible in order to top it up
otherwise you risk covered cases really
surging over the coming months but we've
also got a warning today from the nhs
confederation this is nhs leaders across
england wales scotland and northern
ireland saying we need plan b now those
measures like working from home millions
of people working from home has a huge
impact on the spread of the virus and
they're telling the prime minister we
need that now the message from number 10
thus far has been we have no plans to
bring them in thank you very much
tomorrow's take at uh nine o'clock we're
lucky to have the chief exec of the nhs
confederation uh with us now and that is
matthew taylor hello to you mr taylor
thank you for joining us this morning
i'm sure you heard what the minister
said today saying we don't need the plan
b at the moment no more lockdowns what
we need is people to take up their
boosters and vaccinations
so the government said that the criteria
for determining whether or not we
enacted elements of plan b was the
position of the health service
and the health service is facing a
perfect storm it's the combination of
three things it is the fact that winter
is always tough for the health service
for various reasons
it's the fact that we have got thousands
of kobe patients in hospital and it
looks like those numbers are rising in
line with the rising infection rate
and we've also got
the huge demand pent-up demand that's
built up over the last 18 months not
just people on waiting lists if you
haven't been to see the doctor some of
whom are now presented with quite
challenging
symptoms so the health service is
working incredibly hard and has managed
to get many services back on track and
even to chip away at those waiting lists
but every health service leader i speak
to says that they are right at the edge
and we're already missing important
targets missing targets on waiting times
in emergency departments missing
ambulance response targets missing
targets on waiting lists and that's the
situation now in the middle of october
so we we know that things are almost
inevitably going to get worse and the
question is simply this do we accept
some inconveniences the inconveniences
of plan b and do we recognize as a
nation we need to get behind our health
and care system over the next months or
do we somehow cross our fingers and hope
that the almost inevitable doesn't
happen and stumbled into a crisis
the minister i did push him on that sir
and the minister uh say it's just not
helpful to talk about restrictions we
need to get the economy uh back on track
again and all these talk of of
restrictions and potential lockdowns
it's not gonna happen
well the question is
do we need to act and i would say the
overwhelming evidence is we do need to
act and then the question is is it
better to act early
and take measures which don't stop the
economy
working but i recognize they are
inconvenient for people
or do we wait
wait for things to get worse and
possibly risk having to take more severe
measures so the elements of plan b
enable us to carry on with our lives to
carry on with the economy but to do it
in a way which reduces the risk and
after all most of the measures in plan b
are measures that other countries in
europe are continuing to enact and they
have lower infection rates than we do
but the difference the minister was
saying is the vaccination program we
didn't have the vaccination program this
time last year and although we can see
people
are getting kovi perhaps for the second
time they're not it's not as severe then
and not as many people are dying
from covid as we saw at the beginning of
the year
yes but uh as you just discussed we have
the issue of waning immunity we don't
know exactly what's going on but it does
look as though part of what's driving
more cases and then further down the
line more hospitalization is that way in
the immunity it is absolutely vital that
people take up the opportunity of the
booster jabs and get a flu jab in fact
what we're saying today is not just plan
b but plan b plus and the plus bit is
that we as the public need to do things
which will make things better for the
health service that's taking up these
vaccinations it's using the health
service responsibly it's supporting
health and care staff as we did during
wave one and wave two of kovid so it's
absolutely vital we do that but the
reality is those numbers
uh are rising they're continuing uh to
rise and that's why we need to act now
because the effect of acting now will
not be felt for a few weeks but if we
don't act now
already we're in a situation where it is
likely that in two or three weeks things
are going to be worse so that's why we
need to act uh immediately but it sounds
like you're on the same page as the
government that's you're saying the same
thing make sure that you get your
booster or make sure that the kids get
vaccinated and things will be okay
no because that will take time and in
the time that it is taking us to get
those boosters and we all hope that you
know by the point of next spring
we're in a position where most people or
who need the booster vaccine um have had
it and that we are able to get things
back on track but over the next few
months
while that vaccine is rolling out the
numbers are continuing to rise and
that's why we need to take action to
reduce the spread of the virus we've got
a very particular problem over this
winter and we need to act
we sound very frustrated
by
the i suppose
in action you might use that word of the
government just how bad do you think
things are going to get in in the next
few weeks unless um they activate plan b
plus
i think what's frustrating is that the
government has said that it is the
pressure on the health service that will
be the determinant of whether or not
they act
i speak to health leaders every day in
every part of the service ambulance
services mental health services the
acute sector i haven't spoken to a
single one who doesn't say that they are
incredibly stretched we are already
missing by significant margin our
targets on waiting times emergency
departments waiting times for ambulance
of course the waiting lists themselves
so we're missing those targets now and
that has an impact on patient safety and
it's only going to get worse so the
government needs to
it needs to act on its promise and its
promises to try to protect the nhs from
becoming overwhelmed and that's where we
need to act now in order to head off
that and if we don't
i'm afraid we will once again and we
have been here before we will stumble
into a crisis
so what does plan b plus look like for
you what do you want to see happen
so there's plan b which is
the measures the government has talked
about which is requiring people to wear
masks in crowded places
discouraging unnecessary indoor
gatherings working from home if you can
the plus part
is the way in which we use the health
service when we looked at one covert
first wave happened we were out
applauding the health service on a
thursday evening now i'm sadly hearing
of gps who are being abused by patients
because they aren't getting the service
that they want because those gps are
overwhelmed or are only able to offer
initially a digital consultation for
example so getting behind the health
service
and also there are other things that we
can do we absolutely as i said we can
get the jobs that we need to have but
also look out for our neighbors there's
more news today about shortages in
social care now social care is outside
the nhs but if people are not getting
their social care visit during the day
they are more likely to end up needing
an impulse so if there are people in
your community who you know are
vulnerable you know i check in on them
because they may not beating that social
care visit because there are parts of
our social care system where you've got
vacancy rates of 10 15
okay so you want people to be wearing
masks in public places um do you want
travel restrictions people not going
overseas on holiday perhaps the return
of the red list
and do you want kids to still be going
to school
just explain to me more detail what it
is that you're looking for that the
government is not doing at the moment
but it's the responsibility of the
government and its scientific advisors
to work through what exactly is needed i
don't think the measures you just
described closing schools or banning
international travel
are necessary at this stage and that's
part of the argument if we can do those
things which are inconvenient but allow
life to go on
uh then we may not have to do things
which which will have a bigger impact uh
you know i use the london underground
quite a lot and i have noticed that
there are fewer people wearing masks on
underground
in on the underground i've also noticed
that you know if you're in a carriage
where most people are home masks those
who aren't it's kind of that they clock
it and they put their masks on but when
you're in a carriage where half the
people aren't then there isn't any
pressure so we we need to support each
other and the government needs to
support us in doing those things which
may be an inconvenience but which do
make a difference and so if you can work
from home
i mean that's that's down to our own
responsibility i mean you have it's a
legal requirement to wear your mask on
the underground if people don't do it
there's not much the government can do
about that it's about our own personal
responsibility isn't it
well it is but government plays an
important role in shaping the national
conversation and i think that's why
we're calling this plan b plus because
we're we're calling on the government to
to urge a national mobilization behind
our health and care system to recognize
the inevitability of an incredibly
difficult few months ahead and to be
able to give a very clear message to the
public and that does make a difference
so yes we should all take responsibility
but when we if we've heard the
government say look this is the crisis
that we're facing you do need to act
then you know it reminds us and it
emboldens us to say to the person
sitting exhausted on the tube you forgot
on your mask or to say to our employer
look actually i can do this from home so
government messaging does help each of
us to do the right thing
just before i let you go uh mr taylor
the one of the other vaccines available
or potentially available soon would be
val neva do you know about that vaccine
tell us about why that we're not using
that at the moment
uh i know i don't know about that um
look the important thing is the
availability of vaccines overall and
what i don't want people to feel
is that in a sense they're not able to
get vaccinations if you are in the
category that is supposed to be getting
a booster jab or getting a flu jab then
you know it is there the services are
available and you need to go out and get
it
okay good to talk to you thanks for
joining us on the programme this morning
thank you somebody who knows quite a lot
about valeneva is david lawrence he's
the chief financial officer and he joins
us now hello to you thank you very much
indeed for joining us on the programme
um tell me about your data and the
immune response to the vaccine
okay uh good morning yeah so we so we
we've put our phase three um top line
results on monday
and the image initially results are
excellent actually
you know at least vaccine we think it's
a very good vaccine but we've um we've
beaten that in the study design that we
agreed with the with the mhra so really
good immediate results and excellent
serial conversion excellent safety so
really pleased with our results
what's the why is the um
uk government not not using it at the
moment
well the first thing says it's not
approved so so we we've started our
regulatory process with the mhra and
clearly this data is part of that
regulatory submission so what we're
trying to do now is finish off that
submission and and get approval as
quickly as we can
so that we can get our vaccine out to
people who need it
okay and how would that dovetail with
the other vaccines that are being used
in the uk at the moment
so in well in the uk the government's
cancelled its order so so company
wouldn't be used with the other vaccines
in the uk no i'm asking i'm saying going
forward how would you want it to be used
if you did get the necessary um
certification
yeah so i think there are some people
who are reluctant to take one of the new
vaccine platforms so one of the new
technologies like mrna or adenovirus so
we would be part of the portfolio that's
rolled out in the future in the uk in in
in the same way as we've got people who
haven't been bank stated yet in many
countries who are also hesitant not so
much towards vaccines in general but
towards the new vaccine technologies
okay and and what did the government say
to you when they terminated your um
uh contract
well well they basically told us we they
were giving us bad news
and then they we've heard a number of
different versions of you know what the
rationale is
and we still really don't understand but
we're working very closely with him to
try and get to
a settlement uh position with
determination okay
good to talk to you thanks for taking
the time to join us this morning thank
you
good job bye-bye
uh let's tell you about what's happening
in singapore we can go there again now
can't we offering quarantine free travel
for international arrivals fully
vaccinated against coronavirus it means
the country's tourism industry will once
again be able to prosper after more than
a year of inactivity joined by the
co-founder of singapore sidecars and
that's simon wong hi simon
hello there how you doing kay
welcome to uh drizzly singapore
oh fantastic looks great behind you
thanks for joining us what difference
has it made now the travel restrictions
have been lifted hopefully we'll get
simon back in just a moment or two um i
think you're still there simon tell us
what the difference to the lifting of
travel restrictions has made to you
uh can you hear me
i can yep
yep hold on hold on
um it's great because the the first
uh
the first plane load of brits arrived
this morning and we had a plane load of
uh folks from amsterdam lovely they
landed right in the middle of the
monsoon but hopefully sun starts coming
up again soon um it's going to make a
big difference to us um
during
during the the covet period we
lost about 70 percent
of folks that you know typically turn up
and take a singapore cycle ride
um the local market grew a little bit
but with the return of uh air travel i
hopefully will see a slow increase
uh fantastic now they look fantastic
there's a side cars behind beside you
and behind you there what happens people
just sort of put their helmet on and you
whisk them around the city they stick on
their helmets and then we take them
around all the different heritage
districts there's a nice menu to choose
from um there's the colonial area
there's kampung glam which is the arab
street area was one of the oldest parts
of singapore where uh the malay sultan
used to live um
there's chinatown and there's a very
very nice hipster area called tiangbahru
which is a 1920s art deco uh heritage
enclave and it's a really nice area to
uh sort of crawl around all the
different heritage lanes in a sidecar on
okay what are the particularly uh
favorite places for people to go i'm
guessing i mean if i think about
singapore because i'm not fashion i
think about raffles
yes um
yeah raffles is all right i've lived
here for quite a number of years i would
go i mean yeah okay you know you do your
raffles but i would go a little bit off
the beaten track i would go to places uh
there's a very interesting place called
jew chat chew chat is the perennic
perennican heart of singapore uh and the
peranakans are a mix of uh chinese and
malay culture
um very very interesting architecture
and again perfect for exploring by
sidecar because you're going down all
these little heritage lanes and
alleyways around the back of all these
old shop houses you'd normally miss that
if you were just walking around the sort
of touristy areas
okay and and the burials in singapore
are interesting as well in that you
don't bury people do you
um there's not enough space
so
um no not not many people get buried um
yeah everyone ends up in a crematorium
in a nice little box on a shelf numbered
yes i know and then and depending i'm
guessing how much money you've got as to
how far you are to the front of the of
the shelf
yeah uh i i don't think there's much of
a differentiation but yeah maybe a a
little bit might be a little bit of a
you know gold lining on your shelf or
something
so that's that's some sides of the
culture of singapore you're obviously
wanting brits to come
again it's been quite a challenge i'm
sure as you said you lost such a big
percentage of your business are you
hoping that's going to pick up very
quickly now
yes i i hope so and it does seem
optimistic so i mean the local tourism
board have thrown so much weight behind
singapore sidecars we've been quite
fortunate that
they consider it very unique and
therefore kind of adopted it as a
flagship brand so throughout the the
pandemic we've we've actually seen a
slow increase in local uh local tourism
um so the company has has been safe and
has grown a little bit
during the during the pandemic so with
the return the gradual return of
international visitors i think that
things are looking up
okay and if i come can i choose any
color i want
any color you want i'll tell you what
request either the silver or the tiffany
green that's coming out because we've
got a few more coming out in the
workshop perfectly restored vintages
singapore had a vespa factory in 1965 so
a lot of the vintages were being made
here for the malayan market so we've
kind of salvaged and been restoring a
lot of those request one of those
i will it looks fantastic thank you for
taking the time to talk us through
excitement and some of the attractions
of singapore looking forward to seeing
you thank you
see
see ya thanks a lot
summer i won't be going anytime soon is
la palma this is what's happening there
these are live pictures of the volcano
continuing to erupt 1971 was the last
time that the volcano erupted on la
palma it doesn't look as though it's
giving up any time soon uh does it the
latest that we're hearing is that the uh
second stream of lava from the volcano
is now just hours away from the sea and
if you were with us last week you'll
know what happens when it hits the sea
we do see toxic gases very bad for the
local community also very bad for the
tourism industry on the island talking
about that in the next hour here on sky
do stay tuned our way
[Music]